following a modestly successful release
the shawshank redemption' has gone on to
become one of the most beloved and
acclaimed movies ever made it often sits
atop all-time best lists and boasts
performances for the ages from Tim
Robbins as quiet new inmate Andy
Dufresne and Morgan Freeman as Wiseman's
lifer read the cinematic adaptation of
Stephen King's novella is a simply cold
deeply affecting drama set in the
imposing prison namesake and at its core
is a film about the impossibility of
caging the human spirit and beloved as
the movie is though there are some
secrets about Shawshank many fans don't
know framing a relationship while many
filmmakers have put Stephen King stories
onto celluloid he also hasn't always
been a fan of these adaptation for
example he famously hated Stanley
Kubrick's version of The Shining cawing
it's lack of character arc tragedy and
saying he could do without all the
children of the corn sequels
nevertheless he encourages new
filmmakers to adapt his work by offering
young directors the rights to his short
stories for just $1 in the early 80s
Frank Darabont paid his back to adapt
the woman in the room and gained some
screenwriter cred by writing films like
a Nightmare on Elm Street 3 and the blog
bolstered by his success in the business
Darabont approached King again only this
time asking about the Shawshank
Redemption evidently King enjoyed
Darabont's take on the woman in the room
so much that he solved the Shawshank
rights for a mere $1,000 however King
never even cashed the check instead he
had it framed and gave it back to
Darabont as a gift
Darabont has since gone on to direct
other adaptations of Kings books
including The Green Mile and the Mist
but he almost lost his shot at Shawshank
just as soon as he got it after writing
the script for the adaptation of
Shawshank Redemption
Darabont sent the screenplay to Castle
Rock Entertainment the production
company run by Rob Reiner Rana had
successfully directed two Stephen King
stories before down by me and misery and
loved the script so much that he offered
gareb us three million dollars to take
it off his hands
after all Sarabande had only helms one
actual movie at this point a made-for-tv
endeavor called buried alive
so Castle Rock also promised to finance
any film of Darabont's choice however
the young director wouldn't change his
mind taking a lesson some and the
directional duties that went along with
it to create one of cinema's most
cherished movies and long-lived careers
behind the lens as well taking the lead
so you wouldn't be directing the movie
Rob Reiner did have a hand in the
casting offering the role of Andy to
none other than Tom Cruise the crews
work together in 1992's oscar-nominated
a few good men while the superstar was
definitely intrigued by the project he
didn't want to work with an
inexperienced director like Gary bond
even though he'd like to work with him
in 2004 collateral after crews passed
the role was offered to other celebrated
stars such as Tom Hanks Kevin Costner
and Nicolas Cage all of whom said no
eventually the part made its way to Tim
Robbins and now it's pretty much
impossible to see anyone else in the
burden that wasn't the only case of
casting twists in Shawshank in Stephen
King's original novella the character of
Redd was an Irish American guy with
appropriately enough reddish gray hair
so when thinking about who to cast in
the part
Darabont considered two of his favorite
older white actors Gene Hackman and
Robert Duvall however neither actor
could accept the part so that's when
Castle Rock producer Liz Gloucester
suggested going with Morgan Freeman
Darabont loved the idea and Freeman
signed on eventually earning an Oscar
nomination for Best Actor and sure his
hair wasn't read the Darabont got around
that by writing a joke to explain the
nickname why do they call you that
that's cause I'm Irish if you didn't get
the joke before now you do what's in a
name when it comes to long titles the
shawshank redemption' is a bit of a
mouthful why are you calling a thing the
shell Shack becomes Americans favor of
course the name could have been a whole
lot longer as Kings novella words called
Rita Hayworth and the Shawshank
Redemption
Darabont didn't change it for linguistic
reasons instead he altered the name
because he didn't want to mislead
casting agents or actresses into
thinking it was a biopic on 1940 star
Rita Hayworth Hayworth's main role in
the film is as a poster of covering up
any secret tunnel out of prison but
early on in the production process Gera
Blount received a slew of resumes and
head shots from actresses interested in
playing the title role as well as an
agent who represented a supermodel
trying to get into acting he later said
in the film's commentary track that
progress how carefully that agent has
read the script and how much hot air
floats around Hollywood from time to
time and it also inspired the title
change hitting it big later these days
pretty much everyone loves the Shawshank
Redemption but it wasn't a huge
box-office success when it first came
out the movie earns just 18 million
dollars in late 1994 and then another 10
million when it was released into movie
theaters in early 1995 after landing
seven Academy Award nominations
fortunately for film fans everywhere the
movie finally became a hit on home video
upon its initial release on VHS Warner
Brothers manufactured and shipped
320,000 copies of the Shawshank
Redemption to video stores despite
competition like The Lion King and
Forrest Gump
the Shawshank Redemption became the most
rented video of 1995 eventually grossing
about 80 million dollars in rentals and
has lived on as an unshakable piece of
Hollywood nostalgia saying thanks at the
end of the Shawshank Redemption after
Andy and Redd reunite there's still one
last moving moment there's a dedication
that reads in memory of Alan Green so
who is this guy exactly well on the
directors commentary track on the short
Hank DVD director Frank
Darabont explains that green was his
first-ever agent as Darabont explained
in the 80s he was a set dresser on
low-budget movies who wanted to be a
writer and it's very hard to get an
agent to believe in you on that level
but when jerry bond met green he
discovered a friend and his ally no
sadly Green died of complications from
AIDS right before Shawshank started
filming and that's why the director
decided to pay his grand tribute he said
I wanted to acknowledge not just his
significance to my career but also that
he was an incredibly decent much love
and much miss person in the lives of
those who knew him so while Alan Green
had exactly nothing to do with the
actual movie there's a reason his name
is so prominent in the dedication line
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know your love to
[Music]